the violence in cities large and small
while it is simply overwhelming 77
people were shot just this weekend in
Chicago 14 of them killed including a
seven-year-old girl and a 14 year old
boy
there was a nightclub shooting in South
Carolina that left two people dead eight
others wounded in Alabama an eight year
old boy was killed in a shooting at a
shopping mall that left three other
people hurt there and in Atlanta the
mayor saying enough is enough after more
than 20 people were shot among the
victims an eight year old girl killed
killed right near the Wendy's horatio or
Brooks had been shot we are doing each
other more harm that any police officer
on this force we've had over 75
shootings in this city over the past
several weeks you can't blame that on
APD we understand the frustration of
racial rules
we understand we ain't got nothing to do
with it we innocent we didn't mean no
home my baby they mean in New York City
at least 12 people killed in more than
40 shootings and a dozen stabbings in
response the president saying this in a
tweet impart federal government ready
willing and able to help if asked to
let's bring in our headliner White House
press secretary Kelly Mack mackaninee
Caylee good morning to you thanks so
much for being here horrific to see what
played out in some of these major US
cities over the holiday weekend deadly
shootings stabbings children injured in
some cases killed in this violence does
the president see the need to step in at
the federal level in these u.s. cities
with the violence well the President
sees this as unacceptable look that pain
on that mother's face on that was really
hard to watch to think that five
children were killed this weekend doing
everyday things like going to the mall
and in the car with their mother this is
happening across America and it's
unacceptable what the president has done
is his
Oh Jay under his leadership has been
aggressively looking at prosecutions
more than that we've had Federal
Protective Services that have been in
these states as a backup to local law
enforcement ultimately it's the
responsibility of state governors and
mayor's who have the police power to
patrol their streets as ascribed in the
Constitution but the president's been
doing everything on our part from the
federal side and saying that this is not
acceptable and it's time for these
Democrat mayors and governors to step up
because no mother should have to
experience the pain that I just saw on
that mother's face Kayla Eric Shaun here
in New York we've seen all these
demonstrations continuing you know
basically against the police yes there
have been horrible incidents but we're
at the demonstrations for all these
victims this has been going on in
Chicago for years there is carnage on
the streets of this country from this
uncontrolled violence is getting even
worse what does the president say about
that and the outrage over yes what's
happening that's a great point where is
the outrage for these victims and in
fact what you're seeing is when you have
this outspoken attitude against the
police this defund the police movement 1
billion taken from the police department
in New York what you see in a OC saying
that that didn't go far enough and we
have to defund the police you see a
pulling back of law enforcement we've
seen those mass retirements in New York
that ultimately lead to the kind of
violence that we're seeing in the
streets I mean we saw in LA when there
was an announcement about funding being
pulled from LAPD we saw an increase in
homicides it was over a hundred percent
increase so there are real consequences
we need outrage for these victims and
for these horde and incidences of
violence that we're seeing that should
not be taking place in our streets
Kayleigh I want to move on to the spike
in coronavirus cases that we're seeing
in some areas of the country in
particularly in recent weeks the
president said this over the weekend and
it's getting a lot of headlines listen
we have tested almost 40 million people
by so doing we show cases 99 percent of
which are totally harmless
results that no other country can show
because no other country is testing that
we have not in terms of the numbers or
in terms of the quality that's not
especially not backed up by Stephen Hahn
the FDA director dr. Falchi is now
warning of new coronavirus mutations
that cause the illness to spread even
faster does it help to have the
president talk about this disease being
harmless in 99% of its instances well
the president was making a factual point
that most people will recover from
coronavirus who get it that this a very
small fraction of people fall victim to
coronavirus and in a fatal way and
that's because what we're seeing is we
have therapeutics we have ways to treat
this and when you look at the mortality
rates across the world we are far below
Italy we are far we're below Germany
we're below France and it's because of
the great work we put in this president
takes kovat seriously but we should note
the mortality rate and how well we're
doing visas concerned about the spike in
cases that we saw especially over the
weekend the president's monitoring it he
understands that there are fires he
noted that on Friday but he believes
that we have the federal government are
equipped to handle those fires we have
great therapeutics dexamethasone and
convalescent plasma and REM death severe
that are used to treat this but we're
aware of the spikes and we are on it
here at the White House Kelly do you
fear that people perhaps become
complacent you plan a rally or the
campaign plans a rally in Saturday in
Portsmouth New Hampshire
what type of precautions do you think
people should take should they be
wearing masks if they can't social
distance yes so the campaign has been
very clear that not only will we be
giving out masks but we recommend the
wearing of those masks it's very
important to follow the CDC guidelines
and one other note that I would put here
just to go back to your other question
with regard to cases that we're seeing
it's also worth noting what the
president consistently emphasizes that
at the height of of Kovan 19 back in
April we were testing about 150,000 now
we're testing more than 650,000 per day
so when we talk about these fires the
president noted it's also worth noting
when he tested the rate
which we do you do see a greater number
of cases I want to throw this up this is
the latest on the hospitalization stats
since we're talking about numbers and in
some cases that is one of the key stats
that we look at the overall cumulative
kovat 19 hospital hospitalization rate
102 point 5 per 100,000 so obviously
those key high-risk categories are still
what we're watching in those cases
doctor Falchi and others who is the what
is the president listen to the most
right now Kaylee as we try to work our
way through this disease considering
there's still so much that we don't know
and we have so much more to learn about
it well the president hears advice from
all kinds of different doctors dr. Hahn
dr. Fauci dr. Burke's the task force
comes together packages that information
the president is regularly daily briefed
on this in fact but what the president
has seen is we as an American society
have stepped up we have the lowest
mortality rate one of the lowest in the
entire world and that's because of
American innovation that's because under
this administration we've led the way on
therapeutics under this administration
we've put forward 36 billion dollars to
find a vaccine and we're hopeful that
we'll have that by the end of the year
and it's this president whose tear down
bureaucratic barriers to pave the way
for America to work its way through
Kovan 19 I mean we're all Kayle of
course the president gave that speech in
Mount Rushmore we saw that amazing
flyover and the celebration on Saturday
night from the Air Force and the b-1
bombers that b-52 actually up there
here's the president speaking about what
he says now is a basically a cultural
war this left-wing cultural revolution
is designed to overthrow the American
Revolution we will never let them rip
America's Heroes from our monuments or
from our hearts by tearing down
Washington and Jefferson these radicals
would tear down the very heritage for
which men gave their lives to win the
Civil War
over the weekend kailia statue of
Christopher Columbus was taken down in
Baltimore and thrown in the
Harbor the democratic-controlled New
York City Council wants to take Thomas
Jefferson out of this City Council and
Tammy Duckworth was asked about George
Washington taking down George Washington
and she replied on CNN that well she she
would be open to hearing the argument
what's the view about taking down George
Washington and some others this is
absolute insanity America is the
greatest country on Earth this nation
and the bedrock of freedom put in place
by our Constitution and our Declaration
of Independence has it done more for the
world and for the advancement of human
history than any country on planet Earth
this is a good country a country to be
proud of and the president will never
apologize for what makes America great
but what the president is saying here
and a said quite clearly in his speech
were not for the ripping down of
monuments the tearing down of our
history and America stands with him 71%
are against the ripping down of statues
and monuments and are quite proud of
this country and what we've done to
advance freedom across the world
you know Joni Ernst also grabbed a lot
of headlines over the weekends appearing
to distance herself from the president
talking about blemishes in our history
talking about the nation needing to come
come together but specifically
distancing herself from the president
when it comes to renaming some of the
military bases peaceful protesters and
other things what does the president
have to say about that this morning well
the president again stands firmly
against the renaming of our base along
with him is 56 percent of this country
this president stands by our our
monuments our great monuments many of
which have been to face that of
abolitionists like Mathias Baldwin and
ulysses s grant in Ghandi who's the head
of who is known for peaceful protest and
was an inspiration to Reverend Martin
Luther King these mobs have no ideology
they're defacing abolitionists they're
defacing war monuments to black
Americans who served in the Civil War
this is unacceptable and it has no rhyme
or reason or no ideological found
considering Joni Ernst stance is the
president concern that there might be
other Republican members of Congress
like her that distanced themselves from
the president's views on that know
because the president knows he stands
firmly and squarely with the majority of
Americans
it's unacceptable to pull down our
statues to deface Gandhi and to deface
some of the great abolitionists that we
have seen either toppled or torn down
across the country there even was a
destruction of Frederick Douglass of a
Frederick Douglass statuary any update
any update on the garden of statues I
would I do want to point out that there
is the Hall of Fame of great Americans
in Bronx New York it started a 1900 and
they have bussed 98 of them some of them
are some of the same people that the
president has proposed for his garden
for celebration won't we expect that to
open what's going to happen yeah you
know we hope to see that open and the
president has set that date of July for
2024 in the 60 days to look into this
and I think the prospect of having a
Garden of Heroes is a great way to make
sure that America's students know and
understand history by commemorating
people excuse me like Martin Luther King
jr. and Betsy Ross i'm susan b anthony
and these great American icons who made
great strides for black Americans in
this country and for women in this
country so remembering that in knowing
our history and celebrating these heroes
is the one goal the president has and
creating this garden Katie I want to
finish off by ask you about a recent
tweet of the presidents going back to
Bubba Wallace and the investigation of
what he and others at the time thought
was a news there was a federal
investigation of that it was revealed
that it was a full rope for the garage
that had been in previous pictures the
president those bringing it back up in a
brand new tweet has Bubba Wallace
apologized to all those great NASCAR
drivers and officials who came to his
aid stood by his side and were willing
to sacrifice everything for him only to
find out that the whole thing was just
another hoax that and flag decision has
caused lowest ratings ever
I this was never determined to be a hoax
Kaylie is that help for the present
helpful for the President to bring that
back up considering this is this is
something obviously that the federal
investigation weighed in on he's done
many interviews since then but to
determine it a hoax in a new tweet so
NASCAR I would note their statement says
that this garage pool rope was there
since last fall since far before the
team's
at these garages they also said
definitively as the FBI investigation
determined it that there was no hate
crime versus Bubba committed what the
president is making as a broader point
that this rush to judgment on the facts
before the facts are out on is not
acceptable and we saw with the Covington
kids and we saw with Jesse Smollett and
now we saw it in this case before the
FBI came to that people are gonna
quickly point out that that's what that
comparison is not fair to call this a
hoax when he stands by that he truly
believes that that's what it was
right well the Fertile bureau of
investigation does not stand by that
assessment the president's merely
pointing out that we've got to let facts
come out before we rush to judgments and
there was no hate crime committed
against Bubba Wallace as determined by
the FBI as noted in a NASCAR statement
okay alright Caitlin mcenany we will
leave it there we've got to go
appreciate your time this morning please
come back soon thank you so much okay